bap bap bap and Whitney I would love to
see your ego be followed by anything
other than money that you already have
ready goddamn sure you just be a fucking
slut like already are you stupid bitch I
love it with the shave comes it right
away I'm sorry for calling you a bitch
not a slut though just a bitch which one
I'm sorry I called you a bitch but you
are you made me do this like you're a
bitch I mean you're not a bitch you're
just being a bitch yeah but like you are
a bitch but like I didn't mean that
no you're not a bitch but you are a slut
yeah isn't that what a day yeah so what
did you call what am i what did he call
my bitch question my main problem in
life I can't keep a relationship because
it would man loses their temper like
I've had this situation life or some
business you're put that on your
tombstone